9 999 995
9 999 996
9 999 997
Bon c'est bon, tu vas pas tous les faire non plus !
Serveur ! Champagne s'il vous plait !
99,5
Attends, pourquoi ça bloque ? Y'a pas de 4G ? Ou... Qu'est ce qu'il se passe ?
Ouais, euh on va annuler le champagne en fait.
Jhon Rachid, abonne-toi là !
mais j'suis déjà abonné, t'es un ouf toi !
Hugo abonne toi stp !
Pareil !
Ok, j'reviens !
Norman, tu vas où ?
BIENVENUE CHEZ YOUTUBE
WELCOME TO YOUTUBE
MARHABAN BIKOUM FIL YOUTUBE
Bonjour ! Je viens vous voir parce que j'ai un prob... EnjoyPhoenix ?
Non !
Ah si !
Ah c'est sûr ! T'as vraiment son visage en fait.
Ah non
T'as vraiment sa tête, posée sur tes épaules !
Bon ok tu m'as cramée, je travaille ici mais tu vois Youtube
ça paye pas très bien en ce moment mais par contre ça reste entre nous.
Promis !
Écoute, j'ai un problème ma chaîne Youtube est bloquée à 9 999 999 abonnés !
Y'a des gens qui meurent de faim dans le monde, et Monsieur a 10 millions d'abonnées
sauf que son compteur est bloqué et ça, c'est un problème ?!
Mouais non y'a des problèmes plus grave mais bon, c'est quand même un petit problème quoi...
enfin, moi je trouve que c'est enfin...  Un petit problème quand même ...
Bon, écoute, tu vas aller au 14ème étage, au fond du couloir à gauche
y'a le laboratoire de celui qu'on appelle chez Youtube, "Le Spécialiste" !
Ok, merci !
THE specialist !
YES !
der Spezialist !
D'accord !
El especialito ! (musique mexicaine)
OUI C'EST BON ! J'ai compris...
Ok
(FRAPPE A LA PORTE)
Euh hum...
Euh bonjour !
Je viens parce que en fait j'ai un problème avec...
Je ne parle pas aux youtubers !
Désolé je ne peux rien faire pour vous!
Maintenant laissez-moi j'ai du travail.
D'accord...
Écoutez !
Il paraît que vous êtes le spécialiste.
Moi le compteur de ma chaîne Youtube est bloqué.
Je sais plus quoi faire.
À combien ?
9 999 999
Vous avez dit combien ?
Combien ?
8 !
Non j'rigole.
9 999 999 !
Ah redîtes-le j'ai pas écouté.
J'ai dit : 9 millions 9 cents quat - bon bref 10 000 000 quoi !
10 000 000 moins 1 quoi !
Oh mon dieu !
C'est un bug rarissime !
Une interférence dans l'algorithme de Youtube
Et oui quand il y a trop de 9 dans le nombre d'abonnées
le processeur du serveur freeze
J'avais anticipé la chose il y a quelques années quand j'avais mis au point le code source Youtube
Aaaaaah ! J'ai pas compris !
Bah tu as vu Matrix 2 ?
Ouais !
Bah c'est à peu près pareil !
Ah d'accord !
Tu l'as aimé ?
Euh ouais je trouve que le scénario est pas mal, après
T'as vu les Bronzés 3 ?
Bon bref ! Comment on fait pour remédier à ce bug ?
Il y a une solution... Mais c'est très risqué...
La seule façon de remédier à ce problème c'est qu'on pénètre dans ta chaîne Youtube
et qu'on la débugue nous-même !
Si on y arrive, youpi !
Mais si on échoue, ta chaîne Youtube sera à jamais supprimée !
*bruît d'explosion avec la bouche*
Oh la la, la chaîne à Norman a disparue !
Ooooooh... Ok attendez !
*Tonalité téléphonique*
*délicate musique d'attente*
Oui bonjour Pôle Emploi !
J'avais une question :
Quels métiers je peux faire si tout d'un coup j'arrête Youtube ?
*réponse incompréhensible*
Aucun ?
Ahah, ok merci !
J'accepte !
*musique de suspens et bruit d'ébullition*
C'est quoi ça ?
Ah ça ? C'est un rat ! On essaye de lui faire bouffer trois semaines de tendances pour voir s'il résiste !
Et ça marche ?
Bah... *soupir*
Ahhhh *de dégoût*
Norman ? Es-tu prêt à pénétrer dans ta chaîne Youtube ?
Oui !
Alors suis-moi !
Voilà ! L'entrée du conduit ultra-dimensionnel se situe
ici !
*Musique type dénouement*
*plouf*
Aah *de dégoût*
Mais non je déconne !
*petit rire gêné*
Regarde ! Regarde, regarde, regarde !
J'ai conçu cette appareil il y a quelques années
mais je ne l'ai encore jamais utilisé !
Euh non merci j'ai pas faim là ! Là j'ai envie de tout sauf d'une tartine grillée
Mais non abruti ! C'est ça l'entrée de ta chaîne Youtube !
Aaaaah ! Ok Doc' !
Je peux vous appeler Doc' ? C'est quoi votre nom ?
Jean-Emmanuel Richemont
On... On va rester sur Doc' hein !
Comment on fait ?
Tu appuies là-dessus, et attention les yeux !
Je vais y aller !
*bruit lourd*
Pour l'instant c'est pas ouf hein !
*cris de Norman*
(Voix robotique) Accès à votre chaîne Youtube.
Norman ! ... NORMAN !
On est arrivé là !
Ah pardon !
Eh oh ? Ya
quelqu'un-quelqu'un-quelqu'un *écho faits par Norman*
C'est un truc que je sais faire, ça !
Norman,
Bienvenue dans ta chaîne Youtube !
Ah ouais ! C'est vraiment mieux qu'celle de Squeezie.
Enfin, je suppose !
Bon, je vais chercher où est le bug !
*fond sonore constitué des vidéos publiées par Norman*
Et on peut rentrer comme ça dans Youporn par
exemple ? Ça m'intéresse !
*même fond sonore accompagné de bruitages numériques*
Oh, oh oh ! (cris de surprises)
En tout cas j'encourage tout mes potos vendeurs et vendeuses parce qu'ils font un métier pas évident
C'est bizarre je trouve pas de traces de bug ici
Bon appétit !
Merci !
Bah, attends ! T'avais pas cette banane en arrivant !
Bah non, je l'ai prise sur mon bureau !
Bah sur mon bureau dans une vidéo quoi !
QUOI ?
*alarme*
Mais tu n'aurais jamais dû faire ça !
Désormais ton action va rester gravée à tout jamais
Dans la vidéo "Les vendeurs" à, très précisément,
4 minutes et 11 secondes !
C'est grave ?
Évidemment que c'est grave ! Tu viens de modifier l'espace-temps !
Tu es en train de faire disjoncter ta chaîne !
Et peut-être même ... Tu risques de supprimer Youtube
Ooooh *cri de surprise et de culpabilisation*
Comme tu dis...
Donc ça veut dire : plus de vidéos de dégusations en couple ?
Plus de prank ? Plus de story-time ?
Non !
Bah c'est plutôt bien en fait !
Oui j'avoue !
Dans tout cas c'est la merde, faut qu'on aille se réfugier dans une autre vidéo !
Là bas ! La vidéo "Faire les courses" !
Allons-y !
Ok, ici au moins on est en sécurité !
Sorry guys, je cherche le rayon gluten-free s'il vous plaît !
Enfin, sans gluten. Je sais pas si vous parlez anglais.
*rire d'hipster*
Amazing !
*toux*
Euh, euh, Doc', y a moi qui nous parle là.
Y a le personnage de ma vidéo "Les bilingues" qui nous parle.
Oh nom de dieu ! Je viens de comprendre, l'interférence a mélangé toutes les vidéos !
Et là, là, ce sont tout tes personnages qui se retrouvent bloqués dans l'univers de ta vidéo "Faire les courses".
Calme toi toi ! C'est dimanche là !
C'est pas vrai ! *ton d'étonnement*
Est-ce que tu reçois mon appel en Facetime ?
Ouais ? Ok, excuse-moi j'ai un appel avec mon
deuxième téléphone Apple.
Hey Mathieu ! Qu'est qu'tu veux qu'j'acote ?
Des chicos o' d'la cachonade del ch'nord ?
C'est pas des bruits de rôdeurs !
C'est du ch'timi
Désolé dude ! Ici c'est pas un Apple Store.
C'est plutôt un mixte entre une épicerie bio
un concept store, un food truck, une friperie éphémère, une boucherie végan,
Ouais un supermarché quoi !
C'est clairement excellent !
J'adore le concept !
Parle-leur !
*toux*
Allez !
tulutu
Écoutez-moi bien ! Ça peut vous sembler bizarre, mais voilà, je suis votre créateur.
Vous êtes mes personnages, et je suis venu ici pour vous sauver. D'accord ?
Attends, je comprends ap' là.
Moi je suis pas un personnage.
Oh qu'est'qu'tu racontes ti ? Mi chui pas un personnage hein
Casse-pas les couilles, c'est dimanche toi !
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Dis Siri, analyse-moi la situation s'te plaît
Pour qui tu te prends ?
C'est plutôt toi l'intrus !
*coup de feu*
*musique d'action*
Cours Norman, Couuuurs !
Oh c'est ma cachette ici !
Ah merde !
Euh mais qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Bah je reste enfermé dans magasin tout la nuit pour ma vidéo
Ah d'accord, ok. Bon bah je te laisse.
Euh, juste, tu pourras lâcher un poce bleu ?
On va leur jeter des tomates cerise !
Ouais ça va les déstabiliser ! Tiens !
'tain c'est carrément le bordel !
Pas de problème, j'envoie des ondes de bluetooth
Oh ouais, le vrai Norman ! On te croit ap' !
Tiens j'te laisse, j'ai une soirée !
*coups de feu*
Oh mon dieu, Merlin !
Tout doux mon chat, tout doux !
*halètements de panique*
*musique d'action*
*bande-son du départ de course Mario-Kart*
♪ L-U-I-G-I Mon nom c'est Luigi ♪
♪ C'est la fin de Mario ♪
*musique épique*
*sploutsh*
*bruits de moteurs et crissement de pneus*
*explosion*
Allez hop, ça dégage !
Ah merde !
Cette fois Norman je crois que c'est la fin.
Et ouais, c'est la fin mon petit pote, il va goûter à mon calibre.
Et je parle pas de celui que j'ai entre les deux cuisses !
Ok, vous êtes des inventions, d'accord ? Je vous ai inventés !
Rick, t'es une parodie ! You're a parody !
Hein? Quoi ?
J'adore le
Toi tu vas dire : j'adore le concept !
Ouais !
Attends, le mec a clairement devancé ce que t'allais
dire !
Il est clairement dans le tur-fu là !
C'est excellent !
Ouais ! Je vous ai inventés !
*bâillement* Pardon !
Ça, c'est pas un supermarché, c'est seulement un décor. C'est des pixels, regardez !
Il bluffe !
Doc', montre leur !
*bruitages informatiques*
Regardez, tout ces gens qui rient !
Ah non, pas tous !
Ah l'bâtard !
Si vous me supprimez, ma chaîne ne sera pas débugguée, le compteur restera bloqué à 9 999 999.
Tant pis si les chiffres sont bloqués, ça m'est égal,
sauf que, ce que vous oubliez, c'est que derrière ces chiffres, et bah il y a eux !
*musique épique*
Putain y a encore plus de monde qu'au Burning Man quoi !
Et eux, moi j'ai pas envie de les décevoir !
Moi je le crois !
Je pose mon gun ! À la manière de Kool Shen !
Bien dis ça !
Bravo Norman ! C'est bien lèche-cul comme discours, mais ça a fonctionné !
Par contre maintenant on est toujours dans la merde, je ne sais pas comment rentrer au labo !
Il faut quelque chose qui nous unit tous !
Quelque chose qui nous unit tous...Quelque chose qui nous unit tous...
Je crois savoir !
Un fist ?
FAUX !
Mais oui bien sûr, c'est le "FAUX" qui vous unit !
*"FAUX" collectif*
(Voix robotique) Chaîne Youtube débuguée !
*cri de Norman*
Norman !?
NORMAN !?
Ça fait quinze minutes qu'on est arrivé.
Ah merde !
*sniff sniff*
Ça sent le brûlé là ?
Ah oui c'est le problème de ce grille-pain, c'est qu'il fait aussi... bah grille-pain !.
Tant mieux ! Comme ça au moins je ressemble à mes grands-pères !
Mineurs dans les mines de charbon, mineurs de la
France !
On les appelait "les gueules noires".
Mmh ! On s'en bat les couilles !
Dans tout les cas, on a réussi ! Et ça, c'est grâce à l'amour des internautes !
Et à toi !
Merci Doc' !
De rien Marty !
Marty ?
Ah oui non pardon ! Norman !
*miaulements*
Norman,
mes collègues de Youtube ont quelque chose à te remettre !
*musique épique*
*musique épique, cris, applaudissements*
Vous savez quoi ?
Je vais pas le prendre !
Mes abonnés me suffisent !
Encore plus bravo !
*applaudissements, sifflements, musique épique*
Bon en fait je le prends quand même !
Waouh ! 10 000 000 d'abonnés
Ultime merci à toutes et à tous !
Ça me donne envie d'aller encore plus loin sur ma chaîne Youtube
Go to 600 milliards !
(Ludovik) Norman, excuse-moi, mais j'ai l'impression que t'enflammes un tout petit-peu
Ça va, on a le droit d'avoir des rêves !